هذا التسابق الدولي على القمر من صحه
تعبير ما فائدته العلميه الحقيقيه
اذا نظرنا لقائمه الدول التي تتسابق
للهبوط في المنطقه الجنوبيه من سطح القمر
والتي يعتقد وجود فيها كميات من المياه
والجليد تساعد في اقامه محطات دائمه
تقريبا هي نفس الدول الكبرى المشاركه في
المحطه الدوليه الفائده العلميه هنا بوضوح
هي الاستغناء على محطه الفضاء المداريه
التي تحيط بكوكب الارض وهي المحطه الدوليه
وتعويضها بمحطات تكون موجوده على سطح
القمر بدايه وجود الانسان في محطات داءمه
خارج كوكب الارض ما يخشى منها انه من
سيستطيع السيطره على الابحاث العلميه في
في سطح القمر تستطيع السيطره على رصد كل
ما يدور في كوكب الارض لانه يستطيع القيام
بمراصد تقوم برصد التحركات على على السطح
بدقه عاليه عندما القطب القطب الجنوبي
للقمر وانت تشير الى اهميته ما الذي يجعله
مغايرا للتجارب السابقه اهميه القطب
الجنوبي هو اكثر منطقه على سطح القمر بها
كميات من الجليد من سيستطيع الوصول وتحديد
اماكن واعماق هذا الجليد سيستطيع ان يقوم
بانشاء محطات
علميه دائمه على سطح القمر اذا السباق
الحالي هو من سيسيطر على هذه البقعه
وينتفع منها للتجانب العلميه ونرى هنا
النزاع بين الفضاء الكبرى مثل ناسا
والوكاله الفضاء الصينيه والهنديه
والروسيه واليابانيه هذه المحطات الدائمه
سيكون فيها الاكثر ربوات وليس الانسان
اليس كذلك
من 45 عام لانه يوجد انسان الي فكان
الانسان اكثر الك
فاءه
المحطه دائمه ستكون اغلبها في رايي ستعمل
بالمنظمات الاليه والمراصد الاليه
وستستخدم الذكاء الصناعي وسببت وسيكون
التواجد العنصر البشري فيها محدود